Okay.
That's about the state.
What about the measurement?
Okay.
What about z?
All right.
Here's another picture
taken from that paper.
And what they did was in fact,
if i go back to the hand thing,
you'll see that the hand, what they want
to do is track this contour, all right?
So, I'll draw it on the hand part.
Well, if you've got the right state,
then you would expect to
have an edge in the image at the edge of
where the state says the fingers are.
That is there some relationship between
the edges of the fingers in your state
and the edges that you
would see in your picture.
And in fact, that's what they do.
Okay?
What they do is and
there's more derivation.
Basically, they come up with a
probability distribution that says that
the probability of getting a particular
measurement given the state.
And remember, the state tells
me where the fingers are.
Is essentially an exponential, so
like a Gaussian that is proportional
to the square of the distance
to the nearest strong edge.